all right mike you have so many 90 day
viewers rooting for you we want to see
you win and we want to see you happy and
in love but it's been a turbulent
journey for you so far
how has it felt watching the show back
every week
it's different um
sometimes like i don't like to watch
myself on tv because it seems weird
sometimes
but overall it's pretty good
the amount of support that i got is like
like overwhelming a little bit and i
have like friends and family helping me
out with social media and everything
because it's getting way too much
especially with a full-time job well
there's a lot of internet chatter about
your relationship
i mean the other day ximena posted she
covered up your name
with another tattoo
the internet went crazy yeah it's
definitely weird having like
like a normal relationship just out
there like every little thing is like a
big deal okay well let's get into the
nitty-gritty of things
but i just really just need to know
do you love me
no
no team
i do not love you
ximena
told you that she did not love you when
you asked her
i know yeah
my heart broke for you okay so
what go ahead go ahead
um yeah i was gonna say that really hurt
when she said that
um i mean
with that specific episode it was
definitely hard to watch that i mean
that one i kind of had friends tell me
about it because i didn't want to watch
that one again because i don't want to
relive it
so um
it's just that in that specific time
that one it was like it seemed like
everything i did was like walking out
the eggshells or whatever
well looking back now at these episodes
do you feel as if ximena is genuinely
attracted to you or was genuinely
attracted to you
from what she was saying it's like
looking back now
onto that episode i'm like
i'm wondering in my head if she really
ever did love me
we all have wondered that i'm not even
going to lie um
were there any reservations on your part
that she was using you for money
considering that
you bought so many things for her home
did you have did you
think that that might be the case in the
beginning no
okay
um but like as it got like more and more
i like started to like question a few
things like
leading up to that episode
if you don't mind sharing of course you
don't have to but how how much do you
think you've given her total around how
much i would say rent is like five red
and food is like 500 a month so it's
just about a year and a half now
so
that's like nine grand right there so i
would say like i would say like 15 or so
yeah
50 000
yeah like with the rent and everything
plus like odd things here and there wow
but it's not like it's not like i'm in
debt or anything from it like a little
bit's on a card but it's mostly like
money that i had so it's not like
i'm like borrowing money from for her
okay
well let's get into a fan question
butterfly wants to know
do you truly believe ximena would be
with you if you didn't support her
financially seeing her just like say
like i don't love you how cold she was
looking back now
i kind of think she wouldn't have batted
an eye
that's just my personal opinion but i
really don't know you mean like she
wouldn't have given you any attention if
it wasn't for the money
absolutely yeah like a small part of me
thinks that now
yeah looking back on that that recent
episode
is
we have to talk about ximena asking you
for money for her breast lift
lily wants to know did you notice how
ximena became after you said you won't
pay for her surgery i did notice that
she started to get a little
like cold and distant i'm always trying
to tell her you don't need it you're
beautiful you're fine the way you are
like she just kept like
insisting on it she was like i want it i
want it i just wanted a reason why she
wanted it
but because
she can
i can think of like a million reasons
or a million other things she could
spend money on that are better than that
i really don't know how she got the
money so
well she said she went to a loan shark
right which is dangerous yeah like i
don't know that how that works in
colombia i don't know if it's legal
illegal i don't know i know in in new
york it's
because it's like it's like having a
bookie and like for gambling that's not
right
right
well um i've been looking at ximena's
pictures and i'm not sure how much you
can tell us but did you end up paying
for it mike
um there's i can't really say on that
you just have to keep watching
but um
that's as far as i can say on that
okay
how do you feel about her modeling
aspirations because that's what she
she says she wants to get the
breast lift and tummy tuck for i don't
know i don't think
she thought that out correctly she could
have did that without that she didn't
need that
yeah
just like i'm starting to go to the gym
myself then i could just went to the gym
and just ran outside or something around
her neighborhood or something like that
i think
for her to just like just go for that
kind of surgery at that young age or
wanting to do that i think that's kind
of like laziness
okay well ximena has we all have a past
but she has she has a colorful past
to say the least right she told you she
was involved with a hit man we saw your
reaction but i'm curious how did you
feel when she told you that
she got pregnant by a man in jail
on her visit to see him in jail
[Music]
i really don't know if it was in the
jail i don't know if that was like a
miscommunication
but it came off as it came off as if she
said she wants to visit him she put her
legs up like this
as far as the dad
um
she has told me like privately that he
he did like screw up with a few things
so he's
in jail for like a serious crime right
but i don't know she never mentioned
that she went to the jail
to get pregnant but that was before me
so i can't really say because harold was
in around 2017 so i only met her in 2020
so
i can't really comment on something that
i don't really know too much about
right besides seeing it on tv okay
another fan question aj wants to know
why would you give up your chance to
start your own family with biological
kids for someone you barely know
in the beginning with
me and jimena we actually talked about
it and then
it was a really big shock when she lied
but i'm really hoping
for
her to come here and then there's ivf
so everyone on the comments was saying
oh you don't know about ivf you don't
know i was like yeah i do know about ivf
but if she burned her tubes could that
still work
um the tubes are burnt but what the ivf
is as long as her uterus is intact
you could just um
do the egg the sperm
in like a lab
and then they
they insert the fertilized egg into her
uterus is that something she's open to
um i haven't really talked in depth
around that so
that would be something for the way
future that would be a biological kid so
yeah well
it's a big dream of yours so i think
everybody just wants to make sure you
don't put that to the side for someone
who's telling you they don't love you
and when she said i don't love you
i was like yeah let me just
take a look at what i'm doing real quick
right you've been doing so much
yeah
i don't know
like
why she keeps changing her mind i don't
know if like
like her trauma in the past
but i really don't know
i thought about that but then it gets to
the point where you can't make excuses
for people you know
what do you love about ximena i mean she
told you she didn't love you but what is
it that
keeps you there
with her
um
it was mainly her family because i
really had a good connection with them
brother mom dad the kids
i really wanted to make i really want to
make it work for the kids so
i'm just praying for
the rockiness is over
oh my goodness
her son the oldest one
such a sweetheart
and when he was so excited that he was
gonna have a papa a father now
i just was begging like please mike and
ximena don't mess this up for this
little boy do you feel that so you feel
that pressure
to make it work for for them
yeah
yeah his hopes were up high i want to
talk to you about
a look that you had in one of the
episodes the most recent episode it was
different from the mic we're used to you
had on the tank top with the chain
what is the story behind this look mike
um it was like pajamas so i just had a
um
just a t-shirt
and um pajamas
and the chain is ximena got me on the
first trip like to look over
even though i am jewish so i shouldn't
be wearing it but i wore it because she
gave it to me for like good luck so
that's the reason why i had it and i
just
realized that it i'm being put on a meme
with vin diesel now
i actually i tagged him i knew her
response but he probably gets so many a
day but
that meme was hilarious by the way but
context is everything because
for those of us who are invested in your
happiness we're wondering if you're
trying to be someone ximena once and not
yourself
you know so that was where my mind was
if things don't work out with ximena
what's next can we see mike on the
single life
none of that fiance this single life um
if things don't work out um i would
definitely be open to single life yeah
who knows
[Music]